good morning Hank it's Tuesday I'm
currently on vacation in the house
behind me but that house is full of
screaming children so I am filming in
the vast expanse known as outside
I recommend outside although there is no
climate control which is a little
annoying and because I've been on
vacation I've had three entire days away
from the internet which has left me
wondering how does this end like there's
this great Molly Lewis song for maybe
ten years ago in which the chorus goes I
hope that you forget about your myspace
I hope it slips completely from your
mind and I hope it stays up long enough
for the next generation to find and that
song has proved kind of stunningly
prophetic so much so that I suspect a
number of young people watching this
either won't know what myspace is or
else only have a vague notion of it as a
precursor to Facebook and yet my myspace
is still there a minor museum to my 2007
self complete with a profile pic
advertising the forthcoming publication
of Paper Towns so is that how things end
on the Internet still sort of present
but relevant only as nostalgia and will
that happen to one or more of the social
media du jour to Twitter or Facebook or
YouTube like YouTube has survived and
thrived amid many difficult times in the
past the sub feed has always been broken
the new design has always been reviled
the relationship between creators and
the platform has always been fraught and
I don't think YouTube is about to
myspace but then again one never sees
the future coming Phillip Roth called
history the relentless unforeseen and
that's true of so much of life we don't
know how it's going to end or for that
matter how it's going to middle I do
think YouTube faces big problems I think
it's overly reliant on flawed algorithms
I think its monetization system often
values advertisers over audience but I
also think that YouTube is amazing and
that there's more good stuff being
uploaded than ever
of course my real concern is not how
YouTube ends it's how our youtube ends
someday this YouTube channel won't be
here just as we won't be here and lately
I've been wondering when you ought to
say goodbye online and how to do so none
of which is to say that I'm unhappy or
want to stop making vlogbrothers videos
because I don't I just don't know if I
want to be making YouTube videos when
I'm 80 well or maybe I do like if you
told me in 2007 that 40 year old me
would still be making YouTube videos I
would be both incredulous and horrified
how I would wonder could I possibly
subject an audience to my hideous 40
year old
face and yet here I am so grateful for
the 11 and a half years of conversation
I've been able to have here and I hope
it long continues but when it does end I
hope it ends well thank you recently
pointed out to me that if vlogbrothers
were a TV show we would be in our 12th
season which is a very long run on
television and also a fairly long run
for YouTube channels as time passes even
good shows become less broadly relevant
and less central to the overall cultural
discourse and more targeted to a smaller
but deeply engaged audience I feel like
that happens with vlogbrothers and it's
been really good news for us like these
days it feels like the people who watch
our videos want to be here they aren't
pushed here by the trending page or
whatever they're here because they're
nerdfighters that is what makes it fun
for me so in thinking about how this
YouTube channel will end I'm mostly
thinking about how to keep the
conversations sustainable and fun both
for ourselves and for our audience to
that end I have both a question and a
request the question is what do you get
out of vlogbrothers videos like what
makes this a meaningful experience for
you and what makes your time with us and
other nerdfighters valuable and what
should we be looking to change or not
change I guess that's not just one
question I have a few questions the
request is well I've been working for
this company for twelve years and I
would like three weeks of unpunished
vacation per year I'm not going to use
it right now or all at once but yeah I
would really benefit from three weeks of
vacation per year that's it that's why I
made the whole video was so that I could
ask my employer for three weeks of
unpunished vacation there is a survey in
the doobly-doo below I will abide by its
results I'm gonna go back to vacation
now Hank I will see you on Friday